normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government I
typically am just at a loss for words in
terms of the moral arguments between two
two
uh political bodies that are not the
United States and that have like nothing
to do with me and what I want or my
taxpayer dollars and where we don't
really speak those languages it's like
to Fig people are like we're paying for
it though we're giving the weapon so my
issue is like you got to justify why
we're doing that and why we spend our
tax dollars why why everyone in this
country is working so hard dealing with
with you know uh stagnant wages and high
cost of goods and then someone's going
to come and say we're going to give
whatever Israel we're going to give
Israel whatever they want I'm like
listen I certainly don't want Israel to
be destroyed I don't want Jews to be
targeted and killed I don't want
Palestinians dying but there's a war
over there so I'm just like the moral
arguments well Israel was there and they
were doing this I'm like look man that
means it means nothing to me right so if
an argument was hey you're an American
you pay taxes do you know do you do you
have a good answer for why it is a large
portion of your your savings are diluted
through this this policy of just Mass
spending deficit spending and giving
foreign countries military aid it's like
I don't really know then maybe we
shouldn't do that I know why it is for
Israel but if the argument is Israel is
morally bad for these reasons but wait
what about the Palestinians Hamas they
did these things and the people in Gaza
support I'm like well that's a debate
for the people who are at war with each
other and not for the United States how
about that it's interesting though I
mean if you like I was reading an
article in the Washington Post today
about um the pre-planning of the attack
on October 7th and apparently it was
like years in the making and there were
two years yeah it was like two years in
the making and there was I mean it's
sort of fascinating the um the planning
because they the intentions according to
this article were to go for for the for
the attackers to get all the way to the
West Bank that was was part of their
goal and also to um sort of show some
Defiance to the Palestinian Authority in
the West Bank and also they were um they
had two it was like they had two books
two sets of books they had like the two
sets of communication they had the
communication with each other and the
communication that they knew Israel was
listening to um so it was very organized
but just to go back to what we were
talking about with the students for
justice in Palestine that is a national
movement they have chapters on campuses
all over the country and they're not a
not for-profit and the National
Organization is not a not for-profit
they are Umbrella by an organization
called the Westpac foundation in
Westchester so they are able to take tax
deductible contributions and when those
students are saying that they are the
movement it's not a Grassroots students
for justice in Palestine is not a
Grassroots organization they said
Palestinians in Exile like they're
saying they're actual Palestinians who
are in support of sure I think they're
probably accurate with that and the that
that student group as well as Jewish
voices for peace was also banned on the
Columbia University and Barnard campuses
really what yeah yeah they staged a they
staged a whole well yeah they staged
like a what was it it was like a
national strike on Thursday and there
was some um there was some upsetness on
the campus and there were some sit-ins
so those groups were banned on the
Columbia campus as well I just I'm like
but it is part of like a National
Organization so it isn't just like
Banning you know it isn't just saying
like hey you formed this student group
and you you know got funds from the
student action committee or whatever it
is part of a a national very organized
group that has funding that we can't
track because they have an umbrella
group and they are basically an NGO B
corporations from I'm not advocating for
or against I'm just giving terms of War
I do not believe that morality is
determined based on the strength of a
single party so we'll get as specific as
we can Israel Palestine Israel is not
wrong because they're more powerful than
Palestine Israel wins a conflict and
that doesn't mean they're morally right
or wrong two different groups of people
are fighting for a variety of reasons
and uh and they believe they're right
and they're Justified many people would
agree with one side or the other and
they'll make those arguments here in the
United States and then fight about it my
view is kind of like don't know don't
know why I'm paying for it and just
because Israel is more powerful doesn't
mean they're inherently bad if two
groups are fighting I don't know what
you want me to what do you want to do
about it there's there's really
interesting conundrums as as it pertains
to how you deal with these things let me
let me let me give you a scenario and
and and ask like it's not there's no
there's no good way to do a one forone
analogy but here an example would be
there is a mass shooter in a mall
unloading an AR-15 at at a bunch of
building at a bunch of different
storefronts and he's hitting several
people a man runs up aims his weapon at
the shooter to stop him but he's
standing in front of a crowd of people
is the answer do not shoot at him
because you will also hit the people
behind them jeez I'm I'm not saying I'm
I'm not I'm not saying I know what is
right or wrong I'm saying the if the
issue is it's the trolley problem too
but the analogy to me is flawed because
Hamas right now is not uh a threat on
mass the people of Israel and also again
before October 7th Israel was occupying
Gaza so if for example what does that
mean occupying uh they had it besiege
they had completely cut it off from the
world uh you couldn't if you're in Gaza
you're stuck there for life you can't
leave Israel controls everything what
about Egypt well they had the Egypt also
was participating in the blockade right
so it's not just Israel it's Egypt too
but it's under Israeli control Israel
Israel has a list of everybody there
Israel Israel even calculated the amount
of C calories that people could eat
without fully starving they were also
allowing all the money from Qatar to go
in like $30 million Netanyahu was
allowing cutter to pop up Hamas because
he saw Hamas as a way to undermine
international calls for a two-state
solution because even though Hamas in
recent years has actually tried to
moderate it position and say they accept
a Palestinian state in the occupied
territories nahu rightly saw their
internal divisions and the divisions
inside the Palestinian factions as a way
to undermine calls for two-state
solution so yes Netanyahu and he said
this at a meeting it was quoted he said
the way to stop a Palestinian state is
to prop up
Hamas Hamas also leader the Hamas
leaders according to this article I read
today I don't have a ton of information
on this but the Hamas leaders were
saying that they were advocating they
were saying like oh we're comfortable
with peace we're happy with the
situation as it is as they were planning
the attack it was like a like a
diversion tactic listen I think there's
a split inside Hamas and I think from
what I understand and a lot of the
details of October 7th are still murky
uh we don't know exactly I think the
proportion of people for example who
were killed who on the Israeli side who
were military I don't deny there were
civilians killed in horrible atrocities
but we also don't know how many people
were killed by Israeli fire because we
know that is Israeli helicopters fired
on some of those are areas where the
Hamas people were inside the Israeli kot
teim and some of those people were
burned alive and I don't I don't think
Hamas Rockets could cause that I could
be wrong but what I'm saying is there's
a lot we don't know about October 7th we
do know there were atrocities by Hamas
that is clear but a lot of the details
are still unclear and also also what the
goals were of this operation and there's
a split inside Hamas there are people
inside Hamas who didn't even know about
this and there are people inside Hamas
who well the political leaders right
there are people inside Hamas who
advocated accepting a Palestinian state
within the West Bank in Gaza other
people rejected that so I think I I
think it's hard to describe the movement
as a monolith the the question would be
who started the fight well I think the
fight started was was started by Israel
in 1948 when it was founded on ethnic
cleansing well that's the war that's
well okay so th this round of the fight
you could say yes Hamas did but again
these are not two equal sides one side
is what do equality matter in war well
because if you're a portioning blame uh
and you have one side that's occupying
another that's preventing people from
leaving from living living normal lives
Egypt Egypt was participating in the but
so but Israel open up the ra of crossing
and say everyone you're free to they
could let everyone flee but then that's
a dilemma because then you're basically
accepting Israel's ethnic cleansing
goals Israel wants to drive all those
people out which it's doing now and so
Egypt yes Egypt was totally complicit in
so both Egypt and Israel at odds with
each other and the Gins are caught in
the middle yes but again Israel is the
occupying power Israel controls the
everything that gets into Gaza the uh
the fuel uh even the supplies like
Israel won't allow Egypt to allow things
in uh Egypt being uh a US client state
which gets a lot of money from the US
and doesn't want to do anything to defy
the US basically obeyed orders but and
so yes Egypt has plenty of complicity I
I have
no kind things to say about them but
Israel is the power that displaced all
these people in Gaza to begin with has
occupied them has besieged them has
routinely attacked them this is not the
first is attack on Gaza there's been
many and all this has been done with the
goal of solidifying Israeli settler
cloning ISM which goes back to Israel's
founding so in terms of who started the
fight I think it starts with Israel and
it's their obligation you said 1948 yeah
what started that fight well then you
have a Zionist movement uh recognizing
that there are people inside the land of
Palestine which they want to colonize uh
jabotinsky was an early Zionist leader
said Zionism is a colonizing project uh
Lord Balor who was the British official
who promised a Jewish homeland in
Palestine said with that letter with
that letter he said we're going to you
know I'm paraphrasing him he said we're
going to go ahead with this because even
though yes this isn't this isn't a
inconvenience or it's a hindrance to the
Arabs who live there but this zus
project is more important and so when
you deny people the right to nationhood
in their own land there's going to be a
problem and Israel accomplished that
with ethnic cleansing that's that's not
a dispute now and then in 1967 Israel
then brings millions of more people
under occupation and the the West Bank
in Gaza and ever since then it's been
this current phase of outright military
occupation and yes Israel withdrew from
Gaza in 2005 but really that was just
the occupation just in a different guys
so my my view on this is uh the fight
didn't start 1948
right okay I mean this the fight just
goes back at infinum to the dawn of time
basically to the to the to the years of
of biblical Legend it goes before that
go before before the kingdom of Judea
even existed there wereing my thing is
just like according to the Bible
according to the Bible no no no
according to like genetic history 90,000
years there have been hominids living
there 90,000 yeah and like I'm not
talking about the Bible I'm talking
about the fact that like Jews lived
there thousands of years ago at the
start of the 20th century there was I
don't know the the number of the
percentage of Jews in Palestine I think
was maybe 5% maybe even less than that
and then you had and I I understand this
because I know my history of Jewish
people a lot of persecution and that
increased support for this idea of a
Jewish homeland which certainly ramped
up with the Nazi Holocaust so you had a
huge migration in the 20th century of
Jews to Palestine and but before that
though you had times when Jews and and
Palestinians were living in uh in
relative peace and the conflict only
comes with the Zionist project with this
attempt to colonize Palestine I heard uh
that when balur Arthur balfor signed the
balfor Declaration during World War I
and basically screwed the Arabs out of
Palestine they were like hey Arabs
betray the Ottomans and we'll give you
that land the Arabs like okay they
betrayed the Ottomans the British won
the war and then the British were like
psych we're keeping it for ourselves
that is what led to the Germans hating
the Jewish people leading up to World
War II so created all this they were
like they stole it the Zion they created
a land of Israel like these Jewish so
that's where all this this Jew German
hate just something I heard recently it
made total sense but like what a screw
over they lost World War I because it
the Land There were like pug RS in the
Middle Ages it's been going on for
thousands of years way before I mean but
German sentiment was all this stuff also
in the Middle Ages um Jews in Europe for
the most part were not allowed to um own
property and so that's why you have such
a that's why you ended up with a history
of Jews involved in banking and lending
it's because they weren't allowed to own
property so they had to find some other
way to make an income my my I'm just
thinking like what what's the
solution well listen for me ideally it
would be equality for everybody CU I
don't believe in the supremacy of of any
ethnicity even though there's a big
history of of persecution of let let me
ask you a question so that's my ideal
but the international consensus has long
been a two-state solution and so that
would be like the West Bank and Gaza
being connected by that that little
travel Corridor or something and remove
all the Israeli settlements why should
somebody from settlements where in the
in the occupied West Bank why should
somebody from Brooklyn have more rights
than the people who've lived there
forever they took all the settlements
out of Gaza I mean they evicted yes they
did and they put Gaza under a medieval
blockade uh and in fact they took all
the settlements out they did but none
that means anything cuz right now there
are people who live in houses and they
they have they they they're not party to
what you're describing someone maybe
like moved in later and got a house and
they liveed somewhere the the the kutzas
in in in Israel that got attacked these
are some of these people were just like
I bought a house I don't know yeah so if
what would happen do you think if the
barriers around Gaza were completely
removed and Israel said all people of
Gaza are free to move about the state of
Israel well if Israel did that and they
finally took respons ability ask you I'm
saying what what Happ if they just moved
the barricades and said everyone you're
free to move as you please well uh at
this point now people are so destitute
they'd be looking for water and food so
after you shorted that out and people
actually got their basic needs which
Israel is depriving them of um look I've
been to Gaza I've been to the West Bank
people just want to live in Peace and
Freedom would would the would the people
go back to the land they believe belongs
to them and their ancestors unless
Israel tried to have a just resolution
to that which also is the international
consensus Palestinians have the right to
return they were removed now you could
argue now that's no longer feasible it's
true I'm not giving up my home now to an
indigenous person even though an
indigenous person lived there I'm sure
before and were ethnically cleansed a
long time ago so we recognize that
historical injustices happened and you
have to find a a way to
address to address it in a fair way but
the problem is Israel Israel's never
accepted responsibility but it doesn't
matter because you can't well you but
you can at least uh accept respons
responsibility for the ethnic cleansing
here now here now we acknowledge that
this land was created on on Stolen
indigenous land Israel could do the same
we don't ack that I don't acknowledge
that at
all no chance no chance I do for what
it's worth and and many people manatt
Manhattan was paid for legally okay
let's not okay let's not debate that the
point is if if you accept the historical
truth that there was ethnic cleansing in
1948 but people don't they're just okay
well then you can go to the Israeli
archives and read all about it Benny
Morris who's the top is early historian
who supports this project says it was a
good thing say says it didn't go far
enough his term is ethnic purification
but none of that matters well it does
matter because if Israel took
responsibility for it finally and said
we stole your homes we're sorry for it
now we have a problem where we have all
these people here we built up a state
we're not going to let everyone come
back but we will compensate for you and
apologize that that could be a starting
point that does not solve the problem it
could well so the alternative is what
permanent occupation I'm not saying I
have a solution I'm saying the idea this
what I'm proposing is take
responsibility apologize and remove all
the settlements from the West Bank that
and and so that means there are people
who are there who have no idea like yes
they they got a house and they moved in
they were like wow we're moving into a
house and now it's like the government's
going to come and take their land from
them and then and then you know what
they're going to do they're going to say
my land was taken from me by the
government in some ridiculous deal that
I don't agree with and then they're
going to start except there's something
there we go under international law you
cannot build up territory you've
acquired by force it's a pretty basic
but is the government doing it the
and and so a civilian who gets a house
yes what happens to them and their
property and their net worth and their I
am not saying what's happening there put
them back in in 1948 Israel which again
doesn't matter that's a meaning that
means nothing Well Israel has you can't
you can't you can't go back and say well
back then someone something I'm saying
right now Israel has recognized
International boundaries right right now
nobody nobody recogn the geography of
what it was in no but doesn't mean
anything nobody recognizes Israel you're
not going to take someone's house from
them it's not going to work you're going
to get blood first of all Israel takes
Palestinians homes all the time bad and
it's Bloodshed yeah all the
time if the argument
is equality for all and everyone can
return okay then what's going to happen
is that wasn't my argument you said I
mean ideally for me ideally I said it
should be uh equality for all because I
believe all people are created equal so
why wouldn't I support that but it's not
practical I agree with that the
implication is the right of return that
there's land now where Israelis live yes
and the Palestinians would get to return
to that land displacing the people who
I'm saying you recognize the right and
you now uh just because you recognize a
right that doesn't mean you fully
Implement everything that comes with it
you at least though you have to if
there's a historical Injustice and it's
still causing so much you have to at
least recognize it and right and so if
Israel came out and said yes we stole
your land yes we occupied you and you
and we're not going to give it back you
think that's going to that's going to be
like well we're cool thank you very much
and have a nice day well listen I
understand why Palestine would never
accept that because their land was
stolen from if you meet so many
Palestinians still have the keys to
their homes I'm trying to think of a
practical solution to to this horrible
problem and ideally I think everyone
should have the right to come back to
their homes because I do I I do believe
in equality if we accept though that
Israel has these recognized boundaries
and Israel's nuclear weapons and so the
idea of getting them to accept equality
is pretty impractical then at least at
minimum the very minimum you should that
we should do is recognize the historical
Injustice that's happened to
Palestinians and then work within that
to find a solution and to me it's based
international law the settlements have
no right to be there remove all of them
but what right what does that mean so
you can't build up your population in
territory you stolen so are Jews are not
indigenous to the Middle
East I know there's a there's been a
small Jewish population in the Middle
East for a long time but you know like
do I look like I come from the Middle
East I mean you you meet many Jews
they're from Ukraine they're from
they're from Eastern Europe like this
idea that like like how far back do we
go to if someone came in your house
holding up a Bible and saying Hey My My
family lived here 3,000 years ago 2,000
years ago does that give you a right but
does that give them a right to come and
take your home cuz that's basically like
the Z so what is the time frame then 50
years yeah I mean we're in this modern
era of the you know of the United
Nations Israel was recognized by the UN
within certain borders not within the
West Bank and Gaza it 50 years then if
it's 50 years then give it 50 years and
then there'll be total peace you're
right okay so I agree let's say in 50
years years we'll just call the land the
land and we're done and then it's
peaceful everyone's happy you're asking
me for Solutions right now right the
issue is I think what I'm proposing is a
historic compromise and I'm not sure
Palestinians would even accept it
because their land is all of Palestine
they were there they were ethnically
cleansed we're asking them to accept 22%
of historic Palestine and Israel with us
backing are such Fanatics they couldn't
even give Palestinians that all these
claims that the Palestines Palestines
have been offered a generous peace deal
of the state it's all a lie is has never
been willing to give up control of the
major West Bank settlements that's the
problem here what do you think about
Burma what do you think about Burma yeah
I don't have a strong pains about why do
you think how about aeran and Armenia
that's a fascinating situation I think
that was a horrible thing that happened
uh I'm I'm also not as familiar with it
as just like I don't understand why
people are just like Israel 110%
everything about it all the time and I'm
just like bro I'm sitting here in
America like I don't know why we're us
is funding it us provides funding to
insurgencies have been going on in
Myanmar since 198 and there's several
100,000 dead since then and this year
alone I think it's been twice there is
there one US politician or corporate
media pent who goes on TV and uh no I
agree that's the point the point is like
why why is it because we're responsible
for it and because the the Injustice is
figure out a way that we're responsible
for Myanmar too sure that we had our
hands in there somewhere all I'm saying
is like we need to get back to America
First and I'm sure at the bare minimum
like there are many people who I see are
like very critical of Israel and I'm
like I don't know what that's all about
and I don't want to get into a moral
argument should the US stop funding
everything outside the United States and
go back to securing its borders building
up jobs here helping the working class
maybe fixing some of the pipes and the
roads and infrastructure we can agree
because would the people were like stop
funding Israel and I'm like stop funding
everything but what about Puerto Rico
Puerto Rico not a state but should we
stop funding them no Puerto Rico is
awesome so Israel is kind of like a
client state of the US teritory do mean
do you think that the it's technically a
country but it's used like a territory
of the United States they're American
citizens they they they Ric is Puerto
Ric said Israel Israel is Puerto Rico
become a state no no no no that's I mean
maybe I'm just say they vote on that
every now and then defunding Israel
would be like defunding Puerto Rico
taxes in the in the in the minds of the
media and the people that are running
the government defunding Israel would be
like defunding Puerto Rico they use it
like a client well I see what you're
saying but uh the thing about Puerto
Rico is that the US has a ton of
territorial islands and they're all not
going to become States there's a lot of
complicated legal nonsense pertaining to
to to the creation of a new state
whether Puerto Rico should become a
state and the big issue right now is I
don't think the US is actually able to
solve its own Regional problems with
like greater Idaho in Northern
California so that's a fascinating sit
situation too the uh the Oregon counties
that want to sued bringing bringing
Puerto Rico in as a state would would
further destabilize an already
tumultuous situation in United States
that's why I say maybe thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net